[Música]
el presidente de eeuu joe biden
presentó su plan para coordinar una
respuesta federal a la pandemia de kobe
19 entre las medidas anunciadas a partir
de ahora todo viajero que llega al país
deberá presentar una prueba negativa y
someterse a cuarentena
ecuador comenzó la vacunación contra el
hobbit 19 con la aplicación de las dosis
en el hospital pablo arturo suárez del
norte de quito después de que la nación
recibiera el primer lote de la vacuna
desarrollada por facer ballotage el país
se enfrenta al reto de mantener dichas
vacunas a temperaturas extremadamente
bajas
los países de la unión europea acordaron
que los estados miembros puedan
restringir puntualmente la movilidad en
las fronteras a los viajes no esenciales
esto en un intento por contener los
contagios sin embargo no habrá
restricciones al comercio tenemos
reportes de bruselas
[Música]
muy buena noche gracias por continuar
con nosotros en france 24 sirve a blanco
como siempre un gusto saludarlos
comenzamos en eeuu porque en su primer
día completo de trabajo en la casa
blanca el presidente yo vaivén continúa
firmando órdenes ejecutivas
esta vez enfocadas en ofrecer una
coordinada a nivel federal a la pandemia
que ya deja más de 400.000 muertos en el
país
bailan hizo un llamado a la ciudadanía
para que porten mascarillas de manera
generalizada durante los primeros 100
días de su gobierno se pondrá en marcha
la ley de producción de defensa para
acelerar la producción de vacunas y se
abrirán centros de vacunación para
lograr el objetivo de 100 millones de
inmunizaciones también en los primeros
100 días
además quienes lleguen al país deberán
presentar una prueba negativa de kobe 19
hacer cuarentena sin embargo el
mandatario advirtió que la situación
empeorará antes de empezar a mejorar
y las cosas van a continuar poniéndose
peor antes de que mejore el memorial que
tuvimos hace un par de noches
desafortunadamente no será el último sur
la cantidad de muertos muy posiblemente
superará los 500 mil para el próximo mes
y los casos seguirán aumentando bien no
vamos a salir de esta situación de la
noche a la mañana iba a tomar meses
arreglar las cosas lippi pero déjenme
ser claro vamos a superar esto vamos a
derrotar la pandemia del fitness pain
gamer vamos ahora hasta el ecuador donde
el gobierno del presidente de lenin
moreno inició la vacunación de su
población en quito la capital del país
con las dosis de la vacuna desarrollada
por facer bayón tec la nación se acerca
a las 14 mil 600 muertes pero con la
llegada de las primeras dosis de la
vacuna contra el coi 19 ecuador ahora
enfrenta una carrera por mantenerlas
almacenadas a temperaturas
extremadamente frías un requisito para
su resguardo que se ve muy limitado en
el país andino donde la ocupación de las
ucis ya llega al 85% según cifras
oficiales nuestro corresponsal gustavo
ortega con todos los detalles
es la noticia más esperada en ecuador
son las primeras ocho mil dosis de las
vacunas contra el cob y 19 la primera
entrega de las 86 mil que llegan al país
hasta el mes de marzo estuvimos para
presenciar el momento en que nos dijeron
el mundo cierra pero también estamos
para presenciar el momento en que vemos
llegar la luz
el ecuador es el segundo país en recibir
la vacuna pzifer de américa del sur
hoy empieza el proceso de vacunación en
el ecuador pero con ellas llega también
un gran reto
mantenerlas a la temperatura requerida
menos 70 grados centígrados se usará
hielo seco mientras llegan congeladores
importados y alemania logramos hace una
de las estratégica para aquí en nuestra
zona distribución colocar ocho
congeladores que almacenan hasta dos
millones de vacunas los congeladores
tienen temperaturas de menos 80 grados
menos 20 y de menos 28 grados que son lo
que requieren las farmacéuticas son las
que van a traer las vacunas las primeras
dosis llegan cuando se registra un 85
por ciento de ocupación y unidades de
cuidados intensivos a nivel nacional y
sin que exista una estrategia clara de
vacunación según este especialista
nosotros acabamos de publicar un reporte
de los primeros 10.000 pacientes en el
ecuador y pues en base a este estudio
nosotros hemos visto que ciertos grupos
poblacionales tienen menos riesgo de
morir entonces cuando tienes 80 mil
vacunas tú tienes que ver la forma hasta
filosófica y ética de asignar vacunas
escasísimas para una población con
demandas altísimas
las primeras vacunas se distribuirán
entre quito guayaquil y cuenca con ellas
llega un rayo de esperanza puro que por
ahora es tenue pues ecuador necesita
vacunar al 65% de su población
en brasil el alcalde de río de janeiro
eduardo paes anunció la cancelación del
carnaval de río este año debido a que
incluso con la vacunación iniciada en la
nación los organizadores tienen muy poco
tiempo para organizar la fiesta en julio
próximo como estaba previsto desde el
río de janeiro el corazón del carnaval
nuestro corresponsal valeria saccone con
los detalles
el río de janeiro no va a ver carnaval
ni en febrero ni en julio o el alcalde
eduardo paes ha anunciado que con las
cifras de contagios y de muertos por la
pandemia es imposible celebrar una
fiesta que conlleva una enorme
aglomeración recordamos que el año
pasado el carnaval atrajo a más de 2
millones de turistas el alcalde es
conocido por su pasión carnavalesca
incluso tocar varios instrumentos de
percusión y hoy en sus redes sociales ha
dicho que entiende la importancia
cultural y económica de este evento que
el año pasado generó una facturación de
745 millones de dólares sin embargo
algunas representantes de las escuelas
de samba están molestas con el alcalde
por no ofrecer una alternativa económica
porque muchas de esas personas se han
quedado sin sustento en el año más duro
del siglo es un sector que en la mejor
época o sea el alta estación genera
cerca de 8 mil 500 empleos directos e
indirectos y ahora mismo está
completamente parado el alcalde ha dicho
que espera
que se pueda realizar en 2022 el
carnaval de forma normal ya todos
vacunados pero hay que recordar que la
vacunación que empezó esta semana
todavía va lenta por falta de dosis
y es que la situación de la pandemia en
américa latina' se recrudece colombia
sobrepasó este jueves las 50.000 muertes
por coronavirus al confirmar el
ministerio de salud 395 fallecimientos
en la jornada en total el país se
acumula 50 mil 187 muertes en menos de
10 meses de emergencia sanitaria al
tiempo que enfrenta la saturación de las
redes hospitalarias en las regiones más
afectadas por el elevado aumento en los
contagios el país se acerca a los 2
millones de casos confirmados
el coi 19 tampoco da tregua en el viejo
continente la unión europea acordó que
los países miembros pueden restringir la
movilidad a los desplazamientos no
esenciales entre sus fronteras sin
embargo las zonas limítrofes se
mantendrán abiertas en un esfuerzo por
no perturbar el comercio nuestra
corresponsal en bruselas tiene toda la
información
los líderes europeos han acordado que se
restringen al máximo los viajes
considerados no esenciales dentro de la
unión europea aunque las fronteras se
mantendrán abiertas aún así hay mucha
preocupación por las nuevas variantes
del coronavirus los países de bélgica
francia alemania países bajos habían
insistido mucho en que sobre todo se
insistir en la idea de que no haya más
viajes que no se sean considerados no
esenciales dentro de la unión europea de
hecho la presenta de la comisión europea
úrsula von der leyen ha insistido en que
los viajes no esenciales deben
disuadirse de forma tajante las nuevas
variantes están aumentando en toda la
unión europea en el repunte de casos
está siendo muy importante en países
como españa o portugal y por ello se ha
insistido en que estos viajes se
restrinjan al máximo además se aplicarán
cuarentenas y test a la entrada o
también a la salida para sobre todo
vigilar cuanto antes el virus de hecho
el centro europeo de control
enfermedades ha asegurado hoy que el
riesgo de expansión de las nuevas
variantes dentro de la unión europea es
muy alta y por eso hay que ser
vigilantes de momento la unión europea
insiste en que la vacunación además se
está yendo a buen ritmo y ahora mismo
esta es la esperanza para que se
reduzcan los números en toda la unión
europea dos atentados suicidas se
estremecieron bagdad la capital iraquí
se trata del primer gran ataque de este
tipo en tres años esto en la ciudad que
el papá francisco tiene previsto visitar
en el mes de marzo dos atacantes se
inmolaron en un mercado de la ciudad
matando a por lo menos 32 personas e
hiriendo a más de 100 en 2018 tuvo lugar
un atentado similar en el mismo sitio
dejando 27 fallecidos el autodenominado
estado islámico se adjudicó la autoría
de este ataque
de esta manera llegamos al final del
informativo en france24 continúa con
nosotros para más actualizaciones de
noticias hasta pronto una noche
[Música]
bienvenidos al espacio de arte y cultura